[Music]
this was one of the toughest makeovers
my team has ever taken on we had not
only moved Karen out of the towns in but
packed up all her clutter before
transforming the space good morning
[Music]
the sun is shining and it seems to be a
new right breath of fresh air on the
towns in we're missing somebody here
yeah she's been busy over the last 24
hours I'm hoping you notice a change
I don't even dress like this to go to
church right now somebody's looking like
an owner of it in yeah you look amazing
by summer with an Amish Mennonite
lifestyle yeah I live radically
different I look amazing
looks are different I can look good
really good are you ready to go inside
I've been dreaming of this moment follow
me let's go come on all of you
[Music]
[Applause]
what's missing in should look like a
tiny little convenience store that is
bright and modern and everything is on
view and even if you're not staying in
the end guests will come in and buy
stuff you can sell stuff properties
that's proper little boutique it looks
amazing
amazing what Gordon is done is
phenomenal the story here it looks great
it's like walking into a whole nother
place please God is the dust well done
beautiful design beautiful
I wanted this dining room first off it
was dreary and ladened with junk and now
we have a proper dining room yes lovely
all day venue the menu hangs on the wall
is written daily according to what
you've got available Jeff yes and when
we went out we tear off and we start
again you turn around you'll see the
custom artwork on the wall please do not
paint over that that's the only mural we
need on the wall just that and that is
enough Yeah right you ready to see
upstairs yeah as you come up have a
little look at the hallway first please
go to the baskets and it wants to do a
little bit of work look with writing
beautiful jump in everything's going to
stronger believe it's the same room new
sheets new bedding and a new carpet
no more murals on the wall we have a
nice stunning wall I love it no more
brillo pads in the wall they've gone you
have your very own wardrobe yes you can
use a wardrobe it is exquisite my family
thinks I'm so set in my ways that I'm
not gonna like any of these changes and
I'm gonna go right back to the old way I
know that's what they're thinking and
they couldn't be further from the truth